today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that hit
our welcome to this Valentine's Day
episode this past weekend is brought to
you by skill share skill shares a
wonderful gift to get someone on
Valentine's or any times think of
somebody that doesn't have a skill you
ever see a friend they're just looking
around and they don't they're not doing
anything you're like what are you doing
they're like nothing and like what how
long you been doing that for in the
light forever well you can change that
person life with more than 25,000
classes and design business and more
you'll discover countless ways to fuel
your curiosity creativity and career you
can take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing and even illustration you don't
have to go to school for two years or
four years or anything anymore now you
need to learn your skill and apply it to
the world whether you're looking to
discover a new passion or start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
correct
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
for over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now
Skillshare comm slash Theo von get that
skill today's episode is brought to you
by Ridge wallet a lot of time people
have a wallet you know that and you'll
see somebody and they'll reach in their
pocket and they'll pull out something
that has money inside of it and that's a
wallet and you think oh man that wallet
looks old-fashioned look like it may be
from the past maybe from now you know 16
Centuri but the truth is it is but now
you can get a new Ridge wallet the ridge
is that front pocket carry it's that
real deal that front pocket bad boy and
it is it looks just like a um I almost
like a credit card itself but it has
special
metal that blocks alien if aliens are
trying to steal your identity or
somebody else that's closer the ridge
wallet it's at front pocket carry keep
your cards close visit Ridge wallet comm
slash Theo
that's RI d GE Wal l dot comm slash Theo
for 10% off or use code Theo at checkout
for 10% off that's Ridge wallet comm
slash Theo get that
hitter love is in the air who is that
it's someone in love who is that someone
today's episode is as a pair of
beautiful people a young man that has
been kinder to me maybe then any other
comedian in my career maybe in some ways
I'm grateful to know him I'm grateful to
have him I'm also grateful to have his
beautiful lovely co-host and and
girlfriend
it is the slep king and the awake queen
it is Bobbie Lee and kalila from tiger
belly
[Music]
but I didn't care about you I would
never be racist here yeah we see y'all
y'all gooks and then what say y'all
Ching chongs whoa no sorry I don't want
to start I don't want to start you know
what dude III we were late I felt
frustrated about it it's raining I'm in
a bad mood or you know really gaps nappy
I'm very irritable and so I want to
reset my um Chi in core your core de you
definitely gotta work you seem like a
nice lady I am thank you okay mood are
you really yeah yeah well I want to say
this to you guys happy Valentine's I do
have you started yet huh
you oh you're starting oh my bad start
over because I'm and then I'm gonna put
my own podcast smile on okay look Jesus
let's hope it was something different
than that just yeah I had dinner at
Craigs last night guys reckless huh
what no Craig's the restaurant I thought
was a guy was some guy named Craig or no
Craig okay and also I got this hat from
somebody named David Spade
so hmm did you did he really give you
that hey man that's pretty cool so good
dude yeah he's a nice man is he a
munchkin Oh little how big he is yeah
he's like proportionally a dwarf well if
you see a smaller person do you feel
like you guys like you know stuff that
they know like is there any sort of like
well no no because when I see it depends
on what race they are is it looking like
Paquito symmetry that goes on whenever
see small people no but what I am
no but if I see like a white dude that's
like my height I get really sad for them
oh I see yeah because you know
genetically they should be daliyah style
yeah right but then if I see an Asian my
height I'm like just like normal [ __ ] do
ya do you know if somebody's Asian or
not like is it the same I got this guy
you have no idea
yeah
you know I'll tell you how we know we
have [ __ ] eyes yeah I know my my
Korean best friend she can tell the
different the different gates between a
Japanese Korean how they walk and you
know like the Korean men older man they
walk with their hands behind their back
but that yeah their spinal so I can
always tell site money instead of buying
a back brace a lot of them just like
well just put this right here yeah yeah
even like the Keanu Reeves Asians
they're like 10% 15% the capacitive is
off is why I can tell and usually I can
go yeah you're [ __ ] twenty twelve
percent mom oh really yeah yeah now you
know exactly how do you know and they
get all excited you know who sneak is
the laotians why this sneaky well cuz
you don't know who they are you like are
they Filipino or they Ryan what are they
doing it yeah yeah bullying are they
faking it yeah yeah yeah and then
they're actually Laotian and then when
they sweat you can smell like pineapple
oh my god it smells like the [ __ ]
lobby at a UH at a Ramada Inn in Kauai
you know beautiful scent yeah so love is
in the air you guys have been lovers for
how long this is six six years of lovin
Wow and when was the first time that you
guys if it's okay to talk about a woman
for something you guys had sexual
intercourse probably well I know that's
not sure a month into our money to go a
month but he had to drive to Long Beach
bro every day did you really yeah I what
she didn't even come to my place for a
month
did he or did he drive I drove too
[ __ ] long beach everyday I'm asking
the woman he drove down there he did and
and what would he do it again filth
either he didn't try to he didn't try he
didn't clean his car he had piles of
like bottles and just dirty underwear
everything dad well it's so great I was
like okay well I that this is his
baseline and he's not trying to front
like he's anybody else oh that's pretty
cool yeah so there was no
bait-and-switch huh did he yeah there
are a few but more of a more of a maybe
an effort thing not really a cleanliness
thing from the get-go I knew he was a he
was a pig I didn't hide you know hygiene
wise who's a hygiene risk they call yeah
yeah for sure hepatitis risk
Oh
yeah yeah definitely Wow are you asleep
or awake I had to get my booster shot
did you really yeah oh definitely yeah
he seemed like that guy who's definitely
got that fever in him you know he's got
the potential for uh he's got the
potential for fever
whatever fever oh if you look I couldn't
even imagine seeing one of his blood
cells under a microscope who would even
know it's probably just sitting there
[ __ ] vaping you know so you guys the
full 1 month and you guys got into sex
now how did that kind of start because
I'm or where was the first date less cuz
I'm I just want to learn about love it's
Valentine's I want to learn about gel to
love we can talk about love did I feel
like I'm on a yellow mirror have you
seen that show bro bro bro
yellow mirror it was very good and I
wouldn't give you I wouldn't give you
more of a laugh if I wasn't so enraged
right now let me see something right now
okay that was [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
thank you all right but listen to me
okay yeah don't talk to me that way
okay because I'm here as well yes we
[ __ ] a month in okay and it was not we
I go let me just stick the tip and did
he say that really no she sprinted let
me just to like hit training oh yeah
circuit training oh yeah we did a little
we had stations you guys went to an
actual place you just made it up in a
row in my apartment in my apartment
living room yeah we had stations that's
where you do the air guitar right yeah
that's where you know we do this and
over here you know you can put just the
tip in right oh wow I get in and I still
gonna stick it out you know I stuck it
in stuck it out yeah but she wouldn't
let me stick to keep it in there oh wow
I like that yeah yeah let's I did like
five or six of those very nice well
literally that's all we did oh wow the
first time so it wasn't real it was sex
you know on paper it was sex but it was
you wanna see if it fit you know like a
meeting oh you're gonna get a gap
trying on you know yeah was a disaster
why because I didn't realize our height
differential at that time yeah and he
was trying to you know we were trying to
do it doggystyle oh yeah
and it turns out his thighs are actually
really short oh yeah so um he tried I
was like a yam he's building a yam so he
would have had to done a half stand in
order to get there and his thighs
apparently were burning so he was like I
gotta go home I gotta go home so he just
left and he just rushed home he didn't
even explain
burning thighs that's very so the next a
third time we did it prison style which
is straight flat because that's all the
only cell I can do burden burning thighs
hidden dragon that's I can't do I've
never done doggy the normal way oh wow
because I'm so shut like short my legs
is love so I just got lay on your
stomach right and then sometimes I have
to like squeeze their legs together like
that oh yeah yeah so I can you know
tighten the situation yeah yeah yeah
do you now was it do you remember being
it kind of sensual and you guys been
drinking or is it no we don't drink I
don't drink I don't know I don't know
that's true oh god yeah do you but now
had you been drinking it you had maybe
some tea or something or like this she
has to be drugged out to [ __ ] me or what
is that we're going into the state a
drunken state forbid or calm or
something [ __ ] she's gonna let some
guy drive down Long Beach it not [ __ ]
dirty car I wouldn't be surprised if she
has a [ __ ] you know a couple of
[ __ ] Mick ultras bra for the [ __ ] but
I also kind of just say this though
Accio is is that let's be clear about
this is that she's kind of she's aware
of Who I am as well right okay there
yeah that you have that now she's not a
huge fan but you know it's not like I've
done more than YouTube right Ryan
very true baby I can get above YouTube
you know right it's not like you have to
[ __ ] who is that
that girl Gail um did the arm with the
puppet you I'm talking about puppet Gail
is that uh uh no what was her name she
had a TV show went on e eventually yeah
KITT um you know I'm talking about one
on a he entertainment or vh1 or
something
she out Grenda Grenda no it was on the
III I honestly don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about YouTube what
was the lady's name blond-haired Gayle
bent um Gilda Gayle Bennett
Hilda night time with um and she played
with puppets griten uh maybe not puppets
makeup or something tutorials she did
all of it let me sit down you know what
all this is just let it go
no Jana he'll come up with it I know
you're talking about it she's great Dean
Christine Yeah right no sir she does her
own deity do yourself show on Netflix or
she makes cakes and then she talks to
puppets not like that though okay that's
cool yeah no this was Gail I think or
Grenda or gig or uh
Hilda Helga mmm Herta blondie anyway can
I just see something yeah you guys got
it I love about you right now dude is
that you have some new clothing because
I've been analyzing your clothing for
the last year really yeah and you look
like you have some new [ __ ] on those
pants I've never seen you wear I think
what are those other sweats get somebody
mailed these into US and what Brian
because I want to get a pair of those I
like is how they thin out in the bottom
like that
are they Nike or what no no yeah yeah um
makes these okay we could just do it
after well maybe while they're still
looking for this lady blond-haired girl
no Garrett uh um
Hale big grace Helbig oh yeah
endeavor endeavor it's called endeavor
they do I just get some pans like that
you look nice all yeah we intoxicant
goes along with the Thank You Man um so
do you guys had sex and after that then
what happened because then you would was
there love in the air already was there
a pretty strong love or will you guys
still kind of figuring it out do you
think I'm just curious about love and
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna be
completely honest with you know
somebody's getting Molly honest with you
right now okay is is that I met her
under yeah right and I was smashing
smashing Greg Wow Masen grabs oh wow on
our first date he was showing me other
tinder dates yeah yeah Wow it was like
that show supermarket sweep yeah
yeah yeah and you smash smash and then
all of a sudden I found
kalila right I Drive to Long Beach the
first time I see Matt meet her at a
coffee shop in my head I'm like [ __ ]
this could be a project Wow no not
another project but you know that it's
gonna be I'm gonna know her for the rest
of my life oh wow that's pretty say you
knew there was something different about
her there was something different about
her you know I liked her forehead
I liked see that yeah yeah I liked her
the way she walked and moved but here's
the thing about her and she's a swimmer
she's hot right but what I here's the
thing that made me love her is because
you know how like mythological I am oh
yeah pigeon toe that's part native of
that's a Native American oh my body is
like you know unclear of what it is oh
yeah do you know like my body can't
decide it's like an amoeba I second of
all right oh yeah you're a [ __ ] like
a grizzly Rubik's Cube yeah right and I
have I look at myself in the mirror yeah
and I don't go a like Fonzie right I
just got you know man but like and so
when I was at that coffee shop with her
the first day you was a long couch we're
seeing on mm-hmm and she was really
close to me and she just locked eyes
with me and she was literally interested
in about everything that was saying I
would scare me yeah and she was a hot
too so I was like oh this is what the
[ __ ] you know I was hard yeah yeah yeah
I might my dick got hard it's hard now
you can tell through the genes
you can't tell yeah I can I can imagine
telling it all but I think that's cool I
like tell if I'm hard I tell people in
the room now cuz I don't want to cry my
mana I'm not doing Rio right you'll be
able to tell with those pants you oh
yeah I'm not your junk is dead pretty
clear too
I got that [ __ ] sleeping bird look
you know yeah that's how my dick rolls
down so when I met her that's what
happened and then um and then here we
are six years later Wow
and what do you guys do to keep it fresh
these days I mean I know you guys have
like so how it's we were having a little
thing yeah I I would imagine you there
were 50 other better couples to bring on
a Valentine's Day episode that you know
oh I don't know anybody that's even in a
[ __ ] relationship except you guys
really you know yeah I mean I'm 80 days
off pornography that's the one of the
longest relations you eighty days I
can't that's what I need to do not even
photographs or pictures or anything so
like if he grazed his finger on your
dick right now you could come
oh I wouldn't come they don't even get a
heart bro I'm probably right I'm really
good at that though yes I'm one of
grazing fingers I'm [ __ ] that I have
a black belt on they call them grazing
Bobby yeah yeah I make noise I go yeah I
do that whole thing do we try no dude
all right
I do think almost allowed themselves in
front of other people who I do think
people should be allowed to touch
themselves in front of other people as
long as other people in the room know
that they're doing that yeah with the
clothes on Yeah right you can't just
pull it out and touch yourself yeah and
I still think you should be illegal yeah
just show your dick and to touch
yourself in public yeah yeah Louie CK
model kind of you know yeah that was
crazy
have you ever had a man do something
like that where he just pulled out his
junk and it started all right I'm a
woman right and is it cool is a scary
what was the vibe when you were involved
in the first time that happened to me in
America it never happened to me I was
living in the Philippines surprisingly
Wow
but when I came here I was on a 180 mile
you know I was on a 181 bus from from
Pasadena City College to Altadena and it
was 98 I was with my swim bag and some
guy just and the whole bus was empty and
some guy came into the bus sat right
next to me pulled out his huge big and
just started stroking it like she was
kind of testing a like a [ __ ] lava
lamp to see if it was like expensive you
know in another time there was this guy
who seemed like he was in a he seems
like one of those like ministers I can
really just tired they come hard and he
had his dick on the bus again and he had
he had his dick in between like his
Bible like or a book I'm not sure he was
a Bible it looked like a Bible yeah he
was just ever so delicately
jerking himself off with a book Wow dude
it's like using his Psalms you know
that's pretty cool now
tell you this now that happened the
first time I ever even masturbated
really I go to the public library and
they had these you know they would have
these art books books of art and they
would have pictures people are painted
rubenesque women lying and the by the
river lying in the woods remember that
they have a wolf in the distance kind of
like an apple you know this is like
peter paul rubens and stuff like that if
you look that guy up can we see some of
his art Nick and and I would get the
pictures bro it would make me so hard
because you could see brass they painted
him you know nice breasts and so I would
literally I remember call oh I would be
so hard Brock could barely there wasn't
there was barely enough blood like keep
my eyes open and stuff see find the
breast one find some with a tit in it no
yeah buh-buh-buh-buh
I used to masturbate to Joel Peter
Witkin oh wow chameleon look him up Joel
Peter Witkin some really great or like
Joel Peter Witkin oh yeah that's my
right there did all day every day look
at that [ __ ] right that definitely put a
beak on that chair dude that's my thing
right there that's not my ass yeah dude
that's my thing right there who is this
what is that Andy did oh you know the
fourth time we had sex we did it to my
600 pound life oh yeah we watching my
signal oh yeah yeah oh I come to A&E
bruh yeah yeah
here's the thing though dude TLC I love
it ya know Busta - you know what I used
to do back in the day is like if like I
would meet a girl on a comedy club riot
and you know you're on the road and then
you're you you're in the hotel room and
some older comic told me to do this I
don't know if it's illegal but will you
make it and then you you know you think
it's gonna go further and they're like
yeah I just don't know you and then I
would ask can I jerk off yes you can do
that right that's illegal
yes and if she says no yeah then what if
she says I don't know you then you have
to clarify you got to make up your mind
and you have to wait until she gives you
a firm answer oh really it can take
release if she says I don't know or I'm
50/50 on it you can't take a risk you
can it's like let's make a deal
yeah risky yeah like I'm on the fence
about it and in my head I was like I
would just go go I'd go for it yeah and
that you jerk off like this and then if
they said you can can you like jizz on
them or no I would only do that if I
knew I had a decent amount of jizz I
mean if I've been masturbating that week
or something I'm not doing something
like that it's not a big juicer he's
like a little baby tiny dollop oh yeah
like a couple of guy like a truck rolled
over in a couple guys it's not water
and I just and also I masturbate so much
it just comes out like Visine drops it
actually just doesn't even shoot out it
just cries now it cries it out yeah yeah
oh I think there's a little weep like a
little like you just like you like you
played ski bottles but just won two
tickets yeah like that yeah yeah now
have you ever um have you ever done like
a threesome with two dudes at one girl
no way you've never done that watching
some guy [ __ ] dude I've done that so
many times with other comedians have you
really drive down the Commerce Casino
you and the boys yeah yeah yeah and you
should tell a story about how that guy
how you gave some guy conjunctivitis oh
yeah so I was at the comedy store one
day and I was doing my first headlining
King and lost LasVegas hmm and the guy
that ran the room was steve Schirripa
you know that guy is like he is he was
in The Sopranos but back in the day used
to run Riviera right mm-hmm
and Dice Clay used to call me ching
mm-hmm he didn't even know my real name
right so everyone else started calling
me ching that's the guy oh there he is
he died you know he's alive but stripper
called me and he goes hey Ching you
headline mm-hmm hey company miss Bobby
whatever Ching you know they used to
call me that
oh yeah they used to call that a sock
right if we saw one we call him that
Yeah right I mean not if you're standing
there but if you're driving by right huh
so there was these two open my Coors
Brian Keith Etheridge and Aron Kader
uh-huh oh I know Aaron you know Aaron
rice tenían
yeah that's right I think the last
Palestinians like the loose one
a drop outside of Israel yeah please the
only trust with everyone Dino is he yeah
hey I'm joking he's a really really nice
guy he's a great guy he's the cutest
thought he's a hard worker
if cute is oh he's beautiful to his
beautiful eyes on early hair what is it
about the curly hair nice I combo that
just makes everybody will come to that
what about the straight hair Shalini I I
mean it's an acquired taste brother you
know what I'm saying look if you're in a
plane crash yeah you are definitely the
first one that's gonna get [ __ ] bro
eaten [ __ ] or even ordered oh you seem
like a you seem like the kind of like
little dessert boy that gets kind of
[ __ ] prison but only around the
holidays you know yeah like the rest of
the year this little [ __ ] you know a
little this little lemon tart is off oh
yeah dude I would be loose I would just
be a walking Halldor bro but I would
have a lot of cigarettes Oh inside stuff
because I would [ __ ] myself to the
point where had all the staff video
games tattoos yeah he's like if you were
in prison I go you want you want a
Twinkie I got one cuz I [ __ ] I roll
yeah you want to come get this yeah wank
so anyway I see these two open micros
driving me to Vegas and we're in Las
Vegas Boulevard and we stopped at a
stoplight
and there was two rednecks sisters well
one was like 300 pounds
the other one was 62 pounds oh wow
yeah they all know they were both
toothless okay wait hold on if they had
teeth but randomly okay so they had a
strange teeth people on to those people
don't hang out together there's one
person with and one person without
that's person right but a toothless
person would never never hang out with a
toothless person so there's a tooth
person I would hang out there no no a to
pursue this would never go double
toothless oh but I would hang out with a
toothless so I could bragged every once
in a while just go like this yeah yeah
let me smile like really laughs like in
that song words like let me see you
grill let me see your what and then you
pointed him anybody yeah so we stopped
at a stoplight is and and uh one of the
sisters rolls on the windows you guys we
think your kid - Aron Kader oh yeah good
steak size curly hair but you jumped out
of the [ __ ] nest in Ian's brother a
lot of chicks love that [ __ ] yeah
and this is uh I think this is pre 9/11
oh yeah so you know they cuz I can do
what you want oh yeah yeah and I'm
saying this Matthew disappears broke we
don't know where he is so I get to the
Riviera and I tell Brian I go
but first also Brian Keith Etheridge
look him up ugliest white dude that God
ever made but is he a family man now and
I don't face Brian
God [ __ ] your face up no I think he
didn't even try look at that Oh God
didn't even try look at that hair no
chin oh my god was he you know um was he
was he in the military that's the only
photo you can see to the one in the very
far right that's him right there
I think he's cute he's looking for you
have no idea baby that guy was the king
of insults he was the bill first one
yeah and he has two first names and then
a lesbian right
so I tell Brian I go hey I'm gonna go do
a set list anyway cuz I had to do the
midnight show in the Riviera so when I
show up at the show dude Brian Keith
Etheridge and Aron Kader were with these
sisters do hmm
and Brian comes up to me goes hey man if
you're funny and these girls are racist
they told us that they don't hate you
hate chinks Oh what he said if you're
funny that they would blow you oh wow so
I'm like that's a very gummy blow job -
yeah indecisiveness yeah we hate you but
if you're funny yeah so I have a good
set and then afterwards they they go
yeah so us five we go to my art hotel
room and it's like six hours of
debauchery talking to that Oh as well
yeah yeah but it's like I came like 12
times it was a crazy like nightmare yeah
two on one 101 it was crazy but I like
but around 4:00 in the morning I wanted
to see that four on one versus asleep
yeah the other four does criminals so
check it out dude so at 4:00 in the
morning
I'm with the fat one right I'm Mike bad
and I'm doing her doggy style yeah yeah
I have you know a big dog ever but she's
no no they all that cleaning the kennel
baby and um
you know I'm saying a lot so I look
around I like taking the school yeah and
I look around and I don't know where
Brian is oh yeah right I know where
Aaron is Aaron's with the other girl
yeah so I'm doing styling I don't know
where Brian is it's a couple of minutes
pass and then all of a sudden I feel
something tickling my butthole
oh yeah and it feels like a feather oh
wow yeah yeah I turn around and there's
no one there so now I think is it
paranormal right mm-hmm like I need like
a Nate like a Native American ghost or
something or white yeah yeah but the
feather I'm saying though oh that's
right I'm like a white yes I'm like a
writer for the 1800 yeah yeah yeah yeah
so I didn't keep going but then now I
know it's not a feather now oh yeah it's
it's like some sort of flesh mm-hmm
all my rectum oh yeah right I got scared
as you do
Yeah right if you don't know where your
bro is something you got a girl here you
feel something something happening on
your anus what it is right there's a
there's something right there's a man
with a little sailor over there I love
that song
it's a good song right so then I got and
then all of a sudden I looked down right
and he had crawled underneath her yeah
and he was eating her vagina oh wow
while I was doing it it's like
Michelangelo paint like from you know
yeah the ceiling order yeah and you were
like yeah yeah doing that roof work roof
work right yeah even this thing you do
that you did that thing yeah yeah yeah
so I in my head you don't know what to
do because I'm about to come but also
this is gay yeah so you're caught in a
situation like woody what do you do yeah
go do Dan with God
so my my thing was speed [ __ ] get out oh
wow
I said Carl Lewis bro yeah yeah powerful
powerful cut power [ __ ] is insane
daliyah told me dude if you're a power
[ __ ] yeah shut it down man that [ __ ]
is so old-school you know what was in
the railroad he's a slow [ __ ] he said
he's a salut yeah yeah yeah
and I always believed him I always
powerful because I think the girl's
gonna change their mind
yeah right so I just I can come here
before they go yeah I've decided not to
so I was doing it I start on [ __ ] her
and then something happened where he
either kind of adjusted I adjusted a
little bit and I try to stick it back in
and he got he came up like this
no and my penis rubs his eye oh wow
right when you when you stick your penis
in another man's eye it's a party
stopper yeah I could see the ends it
ends all the vibe I could see some
definitely some even like hey I'm gonna
grab some ice you know yeah yeah early
he was uncomfortable when we stopped I
didn't come and then I just hey
everybody you guys wanna breakfast and
it was a yeah so we go down to the
buffet oh that's like 5:00 in the
morning eating with a group of people
have y'all been [ __ ] sounds way a
Native American bro that just sounds
like pygmy style let's all [ __ ] thing
go get ahead and go right [ __ ]
pheasant you know you gotta tighten up
yeah
so then what ends up happening anymore
happen yeah more it's not even done so
we're at breakfast bro and you know I'm
trying to because I need to sleep yeah
I'm tired you know I know you know
talking to the people
I'm eating my bacon you know and I look
at Brian and his there's a yellow oh
yeah film hmm they had dried over his
eye oh wow and it was infected oh yeah
he couldn't open it right oh yeah that
Polynesian hushpuppy they call that when
that thing gets all [ __ ] flared up
and shuts down the Sun from our from
groups yeah yeah I gave them the
Polynesian so now I'm now like I'm tired
and I'm like you know I'm like just in
my head I'm like let it go don't even
tell him about it
oh right just got you know just to let
just go to sleep he might lose the eye
but that's his bad oh yeah right but
then my other side was like you got to
say something right so much I just got I
got your eye dude he's like what like a
really you can't see through that eye
dude right he's like yeah you're right
right like he should have known that
like I can't see ya but I [ __ ] I yeah
he forced me to call him out idiot right
if you can't see you know yeah I'm like
so what do you want to do like you know
what do you want to do about it
yeah I was hoping he was like you know
no this happens all the time if I kick
it so we go to sleep it'll be better
that's not what he said yeah he goes it
hurts
oh it hurts real bad right it's infected
it's a so now we had to go to the
hospital no I know I bruh what we get
that black yeah yeah so now imagine how
I'm feeling it's 7:00 in the morning now
6:00 in the morning huh you're driving
in the hospital and you hadn't come yet
did you come or not a bunch of times
before that yeah oh that's disgusting
and so we go to the hospital and Brian
you know was like hey guys I'm really
embarrassed so you can't say that you
jabbed your dick in my eye so I go what
are you gonna say he said I'll come up
with something brush by fairy - so we go
and the doctor comes and he goes what
happened and then Brian he's a comment
she goes he skull-fucked away in this in
the story but he got antibiotics and he
could you can see out of that eye now
Wow
yes it's a good story Celia and the
picture can you tell when that picture
that anything is wrong with him or
something I think that a photo was
before the eye mm-hmm yeah that's crazy
BK you've never you've never been with
an like if you and I if I was single and
you and I were on the road and like the
hottest chick was like I'll [ __ ] both of
you
you wouldn't do with me I guess I would
do it if you
ooh one of us who that's like we're a
sheet or something I feel like or we're
like a like a Klansman no no no no like
I'll take you topical of all right I'm
you don't to say you to say a ghost no I
know I was
did I prefer the term ghost that no
because I'll have the purple the put
okay I'll hang on a minute yeah I'll be
the Grand Wizard yeah I say ghost it's
not for everybody but you would know you
would do it if I was like at cheats on
if you were in an outfit or something
cool I'm not gonna sit there and you're
fully naked and I'm fully naked we're
both trying to keep erections up you
know yeah but you don't realize the the
Vietnam War kind of bonding that we
could have though did I've been to a
Vietnam War Memorial Museum so yeah but
you weren't enough so what I'm saying is
that you and I did something like that
you would make us like war buddies baked
from frog that was a great movie Gary
Sinise is the best huh see this is great
but it's just uh um even watching it now
and he's sitting on that the [ __ ]
guy is sitting on the couch or the bench
and you see that feather floating it's
really nice
I'd say I can't see [ __ ] right oh
you could say was he what was Forrest
Gump was he he had polio
you had polio really no he didn't have
polio he had autism just had weak legs
yeah Hugh there was no mental yes there
was a delay there was a devotional you
know he had like a developmental yeah
yeah he was struggling now what about
this so but if you would just I have the
last word if they had said such a delay
how can he play ping-pong that good
because you're not really because his
response his motor skills and mental
response time is off the charts right
right he does that make him he could run
and carrying a black man with no legs in
an arm you could just do a lot of things
yeah anyway all right maybe physically
is it abnormal or something yeah I think
if you have a motor skills seem fine
it's the rest of them you know it's a
non motor and autistics often have like
they call them like islets of competence
their autistic savants so they can do
like a lot of other things weird
well like count or do math or like
Raymond Raymond Raymond yes
oh we had uh we had this boy autistic
boy named Lance bust autistic Lance and
he could throw a [ __ ] javelin I swear
to God
almost probably 100 hundred yards that
was the thing
oh and hit a [ __ ] balloon son they
called him Lancelot yeah and maybe they
know you said that's real maybe they
named him because o it is real maybe
they named him because they knew he was
gonna do that I don't know if one of his
parents was like a foreseer alright uh
what [ __ ] happen to him he was an
[ __ ] to I mean he had skills and then
he was also an [ __ ] well what about
this so you got this beautiful dime here
yeah when you gonna take that thing to
the bank you know what I'm saying
brother you're gonna take that thing to
the bank you little [ __ ] Chim Cheree
hmm you little [ __ ] Pokemon gone
sorry just fell asleep for a second
sleepwalk my bag um but what about this
I can I just do this though is um thanks
for that gig though you bet man
Bobby now when did he get did he tell
you about it no well millionaire's house
must have been real important oh yes yes
I do remember I mean I went to a
millionaire's house and I'm gonna say
this right now I have never eaten a dick
- I mean yeah part - right
it was I I know dude I had never been on
stage were in my my life and I went no
one is listening but no one like me had
finished her dessert and then we're like
trying to get the rest of half of a side
yeah you can feel them like scraping the
ceramic part of the [ __ ] ball I mean
it was baby I was eating his wedding was
just some rich kids no but the guy
before his powerful buddy wasn't like
he's not even a paid regular yeah he
killed how did you do he did good okay
okay yell at a lady though when you
gather that lady I'm like I should have
done that [ __ ] throw him to shut it
down they're rich and I've never liked
the rich and the [ __ ] homo
damn son I'll burn this [ __ ]
down I go to jail for four years max
yeah and I'm out at 40 but dude it was
like it was number one I needed it hmm
it really does when you're when it
really does that kind of bomb humbles
the [ __ ] out of here yeah and so I was
like sweating I got off stage I'm like
wow that's I remember and that in the
day you know you I'm right bomb all the
time and then um give a [ __ ] somebody
else [ __ ] while he was up there yeah
yeah I think instead that they had
dropped some silverware and I was like I
don't think and I stood up for you there
I know you did thank you so much and I
was holding it down in there and I stole
some [ __ ] [ __ ] from those people too
but I ran into the guy two weeks later
dr. Lyon no I was in Arizona dude
Arizona and he would this millionaire
right he had flown to go see what's the
LA team not the Lakers covers clippies
yeah the clips and the suns raw Suns
play and he had like boxes seats or
whatever and so I was walking goes hey
Bobby and I turned around and there he
was I gave him a hug and he goes and
then he didn't know what to say and he
was coming out of his mouth he goes
great job at the car show and I knew
that he didn't mean it
mmm so it was and then I go like this I
go Thanks mmm
you didn't mean that no it was a good
really weird he's a nice guy can I get
water ma'am Parcher oh yeah I got it
back yeah man that was really tough and
all I did do better than both of us and
we were but it was the worst part is
after it show when you really don't do
well and you sell to stand around like
to get paid and [ __ ] and you're just
like kind of [ __ ] standing there yeah
knowing that people do not want you
there yeah it reminded me of back in the
day when you would do like a Tribble run
back in the 90's or these shitty gigs
that you would do and I'd like a Holiday
Inn in visalia oh yeah
right and you would eat it and then you
would that waiting to the very end of
the night to get an envelope of $100
yeah but you needed that hundred it felt
like that because if it was if that gig
was 100 bucks
the you and I would have done it but
um let's see if it was I wouldn't wait
it yeah but it was such a pretty good
money yeah dad waited it was but at the
end of the day again I like I love I do
honest honest better to say I'm thinking
about you this is that um I'm gay I'm
gonna get emotional
mmm not really but um I do I I truly I
truly love you
Thanks no no look you don't like
intimacy did I do like no I give you
compliments and stuff and and I look in
your eyes and I get real I get really
like emotional and then you just brush
it off so just look at me right now dude
okay yeah okay I I'm so happy for your
success thank you I'm so proud of you
and I love you thanks buddy I love you
too man look at me though when you say
it I love you too okay yeah you're
always a nice man I mean look you helped
me get an age and it wasn't for you I
don't want to in this town nobody else
has even done anything for me in this
town really I mean people have done some
stuff but Bobby's really helped me well
I mean you've learned like you know Jeff
Ross I could be a Jeff Ross right Jeff
Ross is one of those guys that whenever
he was ever on a show I remember years
ago he had a Fox talk show that he was
trying to develop and he called me he's
like you know they don't know I mean
they they're you did mad and the people
that are there now don't know you as
well but I really want you to work for
me and work on the show every show that
he's ever been on like the you know
whatever the burn or whatever you might
do he he always calls me into work oh
wow
Jordan Peele he gave me a last year he
goes um hey man you want to do a
commercial for a huge amount of money
who really little work and I didn't have
their audition was it for Best Buy
no it's for arm booking.com oh so my
point though is is that you know there
are comics that make it a web power who
will never help anybody
alright they hoard it right and um
they're miserable right and I you know
I've always there are guys out there
they have really like like you know I
think Rogan does so much for comedy yeah
to get people on his show to give them
his audience expose him to his audience
yeah and they're just people out there
like that so it's like I'm just like you
know I just want to try to make myself
you know
more available for sweet but there are
you know your night sky if you were an
[ __ ] [ __ ] it I would not help you
right there you can it's a no-brainer
with you yeah like I saw Trevor Noah in
you know solid amber again I called it
Matt Blake ACA and I go you gotta sign
this guy and he's like I'm not gonna go
to South Africa I go you should because
this guy is that good well he's young he
is so prolific and he's so [ __ ] smart
so when Trevor came to America and went
to Vegas and performed Matt when it flew
out and song really yeah they signed him
hmm but like you know he was at Trevor's
a nice guy but he's also you know you
said it's a no-brainer right you know
when you look at you your voice and your
point of view and [ __ ] it's like oh yeah
he's gonna regardless he's gonna make it
you know it might take them longer or
whatnot but you couldn't clearly see it
yeah and then there are those that you
see and they're just so bitter and they
have such anger and rage inside them
that you just kind of go pass oh so you
see so a lot of that anger really keeps
people down keep steal from other people
seeing them as young that they could
really bring joy and it's not only that
it's this dude it's [ __ ] it's it's if
they're like that when they're not
famous what are they gonna be like when
they have money and power yeah but
sometimes people are ugly when they're
not when they're struggling and I think
that when they finally make it the
feeling of that aggressive competitive
nature it sort of dissipates a little
bit I get I don't know I'll get more
chip you're right in the past couple of
months I've been a lot more like just
stressed out I think and just like short
about things and I've never been a mom I
can tell that with you though logo it's
I really I really I mean up but I know
that you're busy and you have but do
this is a real exciting time for you
yeah it even for me it's like you know I
have a lot going on you know and uh you
know how to fly to [ __ ] Hawaii to zin
then I gotta fly back to do Irvine like
I'm shooting a movie and then that night
when I shoot I have to fly back are you
in the Sandler movie yeah yeah you are
it was just like took a place but
go they try to give me a part in it and
then did they offer you one no they will
they didn't but it was for yeah yeah I
just say this Oh huh
it was hi someone young it was like a
young kind of mix guy that had been in a
fire I guess maybe you got it it was for
kind of like I think it was like a
Hawaiian Frederick Douglass everyday but
with like a glue cut glue kitchen yeah
well yeah whoo God I'm gonna say this
though is that I for 22 years have
auditioned for every atom sound Wow and
I never got him I came close a couple of
times but like you know so that's what
I'm doing but anyway I'm you know
there's a lot going on and you've got a
lot going on and I know it could feel
overwhelming yeah but at the end of the
day dude it's like you know you have
your silver guy yeah you're good dude
you work hard you're very very [ __ ]
funny so hard to give thanks brah we're
always nice oh you know why yeah that's
a lot somebody know what he's good at
talking his way into people in me he's a
sweet guy yeah I think so I you know
it's weird for somebody who gives so
many compliments he can't take him no he
can't even hear you sometimes me I'm the
[ __ ] worst ugh he's untouchable
emotionally in a lot of ways yeah I'd
say so
mm-hmm yeah yeah I don't know what it is
when people go good job I come now yeah
we you just can't even but the problem
is you hear but you know it doesn't
really it doesn't land and on us
sometimes this comedian that doesn't
think it's it's like it's like it's the
thing is that I don't do it for that
right right it did you do it because
that's just what you do I think
eventually I mean back in the day was
about like oh I'm following my dreams
and taking risks and you know putting
one foot in front of the other and you
know when you take a risk other doors
open on whatever right and you work
really hard but what and Shania is funny
yeah yeah but it's like yeah but then
eventually you do it because this is
what you do right yeah it becomes just a
part of your everyday life
show business yeah yeah and yeah yeah
and then what happens is that you forget
you know the excitement of it and why
you did in the [ __ ] first place
yeah like we were the first time you you
killed that you literally got a laugh in
a club yeah and then you got offstage
and some random person said whoa you're
funny and then that night you would go
home lay in your bed and just and just
dream yeah and you're so happy because
you're so well because you you didn't
know that you could do that right and
and it's it's okay if you know it's an
otherworldly kind of experience like I
can do this yeah and you're laying in
bed and you're like like anything is
possible and then years go by you get a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah you become angry guy
it's [ __ ] weird it is I gotta be able
to fine I'm gonna look at my life and
look at what I have in my life and go
this is it this is it this is it
everything that I ever want is now right
I couldn't no one wanted to [ __ ] me back
in the day don't look at her kalila say
I was unfuckable back in the day yeah
you know I don't think you were ever
unfuckable you probably had a really
shitty attitude yeah I could see you
thankfully yourself and also you know
thinking Danny I'm Daniel Dae Kim or
whatever that guy's name was I would
never have ever thought I was Daniel
dick him Daniel day-lewis that's why man
yeah but they're like oh look at me like
um baby babe you know you don't know you
say that a lot
I'm a that because I'm a traphouse
yellow boy out here flex and you know
like are wearing gold chains or doing I
could see you yeah getting Flossie down
there you lower my Civic yeah my Honda
Civic put rims on yeah yeah yeah turn up
a little Buckcherry and [ __ ] crazy I
like them yeah I'm gonna tell you right
now kalila I was I really did
mainly was unfuckable Wow I think that
you I'm not saying you weren't but I
don't think it was from your physical
appearance yes I think it was from the
inside yeah the inside was broken oh
yeah I had no confidence and what stand
up did for me was give me confidence
like I said it's like I know the outs
I could I could have been deer dealt a
better of me a better hand I have
fingers and they're handsome right
yeah thank you I think you're handsome
guy there's a nice I see you at the
comedy show I'm like oh wow Bobby's
looking handsomer than he has been
and and that always is exciting you know
and I think but what about this that I'm
curious about is yeah would you if you
had to let because I know that you
obviously have sided with crystally I
heard you guys say I didn't say anything
Theo it was all out of this guy's mouth
okay well I heard Robin Everland
okay well I heard a little Robbie over
here [ __ ] say that if he had to side
with me or Dahlia that he was with the
Lea till the end listen friend our
friend now yeah yeah listen friend all
right let's hear let's walk a little bit
of it though can we see exactly what was
said Nicholas hmm thank you very much
because this kind of stuff I feel like
is where people draw lines you know but
what do I know
I'm just a young man making his dreams
come true so okay let's take let's hear
that clip I say I'm gonna say something
else to you and I'm gonna look in your
eye okay
and that's Bobby he sounds like a cat
with like a little bit of emphysema not
that there is one but if there was ever
a war between you and Theo von yeah if
there was ever a war he's left you you
have my assurance yeah this is a slept
Kingdom mm-hmm much and they call him a
slept Kingdom cuz he sleeps 21 hours a
day and yeah the Queen lady asleep one
advantage of his freedom here in America
let's hear more my people the papyrus
will back you like you're the king of
the north
that's very cool you're the king of the
north yeah the king in the north
couldn't land in st. Louis absolutely
unbelievable king of the north wait he
can't even get to the Midwest and my
clan my my people clan did you hear that
I don't use that kind of terminology
on your team thank you [ __ ] the Rat King
alas I love you as a person the true did
you just say what I just said that I
love I love him like a what like a Bob
are on your team thank you [ __ ] the Rat
King
what last I love you as a person yes I
love them as a person and that's the
truth in that I believe that part you do
believe that part I just want to know
when the [ __ ] [ __ ] hits the well that
that scenario is literally never gonna
happen when the [ __ ] hits the RSS feed I
want an whose pod you're [ __ ] rolling
with something right but what I'm saying
is is that I'm just I'm just stirring it
up but why are you pick him because he's
taller who would you let bang kalila now
we're getting into it now we're getting
into it okay yeah all right I'm gonna
say that choose who I would bang yeah
yeah go ahead
you should choose first you know what
CEO I've always had a great relationship
with you but if ever you need something
you always you know you're on a few
people who still leaves voicemails oh
nice lengthy thoughtful ones thank you
so I would use a huge that's why they
don't know any better
150% she said okay Oh sex thank you okay
I want to I want to say this okay yeah
Oh like I'm so angry that my insides are
making noises yeah here's the deal dude
you cannot tell me right now in terms of
sexual violence thank you sexually is
that we were saying sexually you are
yeah okay okay I'm just say it's it's
like this it's like seeing um let's just
let me let me finish
it's like seeing it's at comparing like
Tom Hardy who'd you [ __ ] Tom Hardy or
Simon Pegg yeah who's Simon Pegg did
answer no yeah he's a good actor dancer
wolves I haven't seen that yeah yeah all
right you're both mission impossible
oh there you go mission impossible yeah
you're both cute right but you know yes
peg hmm amazing British yeah yeah I
could see that he's super talented
though he's super talented the Lord's uh
a little bit of the Lord maybe I'll
listen to know Theo you're very handsome
and cute he's just got a little extra
elements
he's got more shuttler yet he's got more
shoulders hmm his parents brought her
here's basically that's they mated
they've his parents these grandparents
mated his parents yeah so that they
would have children of healthy skeleton
and you know occipital areas you've
another thing that's not fair yeah and
I'll tell you why I mean it and also at
the end of the day I'm just [ __ ]
kiddin I was money I would never to
sides and I love you so much crazy oh he
grew up with a silver spoon in his mouth
so he doesn't know the blue-collar
struggle so that's why I would choose
you just based on the whole Louisiana
you know um okay I want to say this very
similar to Philippine yep yeah by the
water give you that helping each other
out of a look at the shoulders done yeah
shoulders dude that's that right there
dude is shape of water bro you want to
talk about shape of water right there I
did shape a water dude that is shape of
[ __ ] fresca bro yeah look he has deck
stereo bruh yeah but can I just say this
though you know long he's gonna live
probably another four years and like
he's wearing colored contact lenses
okay so want to bring that up and his
dogs don't even live at his house
the lady brings him over for Instagram
and then take some back turn around
butters got a pet owner huh yeah yeah
and actually there's three of them and
only two of them they ever used in its
like that of mary-kate national it's
insane man sweetie you have it wrong oh
when I when I was a middle school and
growing up yes we had money but when I
hit high school my parents went bankrupt
yeah that's why you would they had to
sell the house but the house I know but
up until you're about 17 18 you live I
like we visited your old 17 it's a very
rich I grew up in a white area yeah but
I can have note I have no control over
where we live did you ever have a bus
pass
I know no what is that yeah do you know
what the MTA is No
normal people and you had a computer
your whole life yeah we have computers
like normal in a swimming pool and have
you ever had a black man's hair drip on
your lap because you had to sit so close
up behind him on a bus no but I had a
gazebo a tennis court and also swimming
and he lived in the Country Club
we had a country club as well bro huh
you're not talking about being in
country brain I think about the mekong
delta daddy are you but in the sense
though in the sense of Chris D'Elia you
know as a kid his dad wasn't show
business yeah and when he was a kid
apparently they used to call Chris into
the room and Chris would do these like
little plays while they're in bed his
parents in bed and he would do these
funny little plays that he would make up
and they would Bravo
you know Bravo right and in our heard is
that they would encourage that right
when I did that my dad beat me
Yeah right when I when I said I was
going to do stand-up they said if you do
you don't ever call me again
Wow right and then for years he wouldn't
talk to me my dad because I was doing
stand-up right it's only when I did The
Tonight Show in 2000 he believed in it
yeah he called me crying Wow because
really yet you met his father or not
yeah yeah what does he seem like and his
dad isn't able to speak a lot anymore
since he's had a couple strokes
oh but his dad loves me I think I think
I bet he loves because he knows you're
gonna take care of Bobby probably and
you know what I would I when I'm over at
his parents house I feel like I I take
care of everyone yeah well bro I'm gonna
say this the reason why this [ __ ]
Filipino lady is a [ __ ] survivor is
the first night because my dad had
strokes right we go to Phoenix to stay
at their house and you know they don't
know her at all and my parents are
old-school Koreans they don't barely
speak English you look the same look
similar they all look the same yes or no
the same ID yeah so anyway right yeah we
spend the night we sleep that night the
first night oh yeah and I see Bobby he's
taking a rest huh parents are dying when
I go on see
three in the morning dude I'm wait I
wake up and I hear laughter in the house
she had gone down help my dad with all
that like medical stuff mm-hmm and
they're laughing and she's like she's oh
they're already in love with her yeah
right this woman right here is a [ __ ]
survivor day yeah she'll survive
anything bro
cuz most girls would be like I don't
know that well I don't know what to do
right
but this girl I that's why I'm in love
with this girl amen
in every social situation I could go
anywhere like any party mm-hmm and she I
know that she will be able to survive
any elements even there if they're stars
politicians even if it's just like you
know people that work at Home Depot or
whatever she be look like and survive it
some girls girlfriends I've had
I'd like I can't take it yeah they
struggle a struggle she could survive it
every social situation and that's why
it's very good to have a girl she also I
love her yeah but but she's she's got
everything there's a chameleon yeah
chameleon she's a bright spot man
she's definitely she definitely has
added a lot more to your life like when
I see people aren't like Bobby Lee
anymore like Oh Bobby and kalila and
it's nice that you got something that is
a little more rewarding you know going
on and you know the nicest piece of tire
I've ever seen on you is kalila you know
that but I wouldn't have tiger belly my
podcast yeah I know it's it and it's
cool it's cool to see man it's nice to
see it's inclusive you guys are via a
you're nobody's Vietnamese and it's like
you know it's like it's exciting man and
I think it is it's fun to see you guys
taking on like things together were you
guys ever considered doing like a
television show you think and probably
not me and you want somebody I know I do
Tiger belly and I do it because I feel
like I said him up well and that's my
role in the podcast we have sort of this
like antagonistic thing going on but I
like I actually prefer not to ever know
what drives being everyone camera ever
in the podcast world - I was dying when
I had to do your man a pilot you killed
it man you're bad you did a great job
Roger God he did it he was so that was a
fun do you kill the pain I know but
was like internally dying that was fun
you're like the Meryl Streep of Island
gooks oh yeah they call you a Meryl
Streep but no I thought you did a great
job you and me talking the [ __ ]
beginning is funny Rogers a handsome guy
was nice to see him there your mom came
out yeah that was a funny dude dude I'm
saying I'll have the duck yeah that's
why I said but that's why we're all like
a family issue and here's a thing do too
is is that even in now the podcast world
like I know now that youth fighter in
the kid dilio and we're all you know
we're all helping each other grow and
whatnot right but I'm just tired of like
now actors are doing it yeah the all
these actors are not doing it doing it
yeah what's his name Ferris Bueller has
one coming out Matthew Broderick yeah
was it good with the call I don't know
some [ __ ] killing people in London game
Alesi no you know you ran over somebody
no you ran over somebody in England hey
ro and killed somebody in England well
he it was cuz he has stolen that car
from his [ __ ] parents period but no
everybody's didn't kill NZ did he kill
somebody
yeah he crossed the wrong lane and
collided head-on with a Volvo mmm
killing the other brother in Ireland Oh
in Ireland in Ireland back in 1987 and
he killed somebody right two people
oh-ho my god a 30 year old and a 63 year
old sloth killed instantly
oh my you know there's a famous story of
a a comedian named Vance was his name
and he was there was somebody had gone
twas it was sexually raping women a
black got the black eye right at
different was he black
I don't think it was like no no it was a
comic that did here's a comic who did he
Holland's tour right can you find out
what he looked like what would he look
like yeah comedian college store rapist
and so somebody even raping women at
different college campuses they couldn't
figure out who it was like what is this
and then they realized a comedian had
been going was performing at these
different schools and that's what was
happening you're raping people yeah yeah
Ravin people I guess like and so it
the end he went to he went to on trial
so when I said black guy Vince chant
when I said black guy was I right
yeah it looks black in these pictures
you know yeah yeah Vince champ
and dude that somebody's gotta do a
movie about this guy oh they definitely
show any oh that's amazing ID like a
dark movie about a guy who doing imagine
a guy trying to give laughter in college
campuses but he's no the whole time he's
thinking rape on one stage yeah I got it
might have been the guy on the 181 bus
from Pasadena City College look at that
he was spotted fleeing the scene on an
attempted rape in Pasadena City College
remember when I told you about the story
about the 181 bus from PCC yeah earlier
yeah 1997 and he asked the women to pray
for them after he was / he was
prosecuted and convicted in Kansas
now here's what I wanted to tell you
there was a there's long been a story
that he the doctor the the judge said
you're gonna get 25 years right since
seven 25 years in jail and he stood up
and goes thank you your honor can you
light me at 15 that's what he said
so [ __ ] up so funny he didn't say that
yeah are you being a you kids know
that's a death the better so [ __ ]
funny can you light me at 15 that's fun
and that's the comedian from here can
you give me the light at this time he
was only into butt sex to be raped but
yeah just just look and always all he
would cover their heads and then engage
in anal sex it's well he's a little
before his time because this was it's
more popular now I know but sex is on a
decline video oh yeah Wow people are
getting sick well people are just
realizing how just it's once it goes in
it's sort of just an abyss yeah there's
no tightening of the walls or any type
of like Kegel you know and yeah there's
no real party going on after though you
know unless you're into you know scat
sex like him I'm sorry I mean Noah he
likes the smell of poo yeah people don't
mind a little bit of it you not also
ever been to some of those I mean some
countries you go to it's like
today I'm aphrodisiac yeah some of the
beltway's over there you know you get
everything else had a sigh amber and you
can't even [ __ ] finish the sandwich
without catching a hit of [ __ ] you
know that body purgatory bro duty it so
I'm really interested in comics that
something like that happen like he did
that but then there's that other tape
back in the day of that guitar comic
snapping onstage I saw that him beating
you know guy in the front row with the
that was so we were angry
[Music]
I'm sorry man
the guy [ __ ] came at me what do you
think both okay he said show's over cuz
Oh bollocks people we're gonna sit there
and wait for the next act you know
whatever you what did we was the opener
you like doing guest spot dude yeah five
minute guess spot have you ever had an
instance like that nope and the head
letters back there's like you know
imagine were you afraid to bring your
parents to watch Bobby the first time
yeah
you're excited yeah my my family is very
chill and open and or Filipino yeah yeah
I'll tell you so we have on the further
man up so we just did an actual pilot
right so thank you guys we got real Lou
you got real legitimate people to do
with this head well no we got a free Jim
Jefferies winning the link those are
higher love it's a higher elevated thing
we were your Youtube version that's fine
I'm not offended we're friends we used
you for that you used us for the YouTube
and now for the real pilot the really
bigger stars I didn't really use I felt
I lower helping him out yeah you guys
were helping me out I did feel that and
I did in the end one of the thought that
one of the fun takeaways was I thought
it was something cute for kalila nor
said that half of it was really good
thank you
and even he did a great job and he said
he had fun I remember yeah yeah he was
really excited he did he looked handsome
he could be a double-oh-seven kind of
like in a Nebraska sort of James Bond or
you know or a little bit not Nebraska
but maybe like alpha 10 near Commerce
Casino
but here's what I like to say is that so
when this new when we had to get we're
doing a butler where some young fella
didn't he wasn't cleaning up around the
house he's living with his mom he's 30
so we wanted to take him to Butler
school so there's a guy that works in my
building who cleans like the elevators
and the stairs and everything a latino
guy named Kwan so he and I always try
and communicate but we can't because
neither one of us speak to other
language but I was like one man Jana
televisi own you know yeah - no matter
so next thing you know I got his number
one
shows up at the place right so next you
know he's in the sketch right oh wow so
we're all at Butler school everybody's
learning how to be a butler he thinks
we're learning how to be double-oh-seven
like monkey yeah no really
oh dude so sometimes I just kind of tap
in oh yeah yeah anything the whole thing
is so great did he was Whitney and Jim
in that scene
no Whitney and Jimmer and another one
about we try to learn about feminism me
and Jim Jefferies gentlemen yeah yeah I
mean I love the fact that you use that
kinda thing you know it was hilarious
it was funny man probably also it you
know little things like that probably
changes his perception of what he liked
and what he's capable of yeah and the
funny thing was by the end of the day no
doubt he was becoming like the star the
thing like he started like getting into
it like even with the language barrier
right yeah like he started getting into
it like it but he was really good like
nah like his timing was good it was
bizarre Moni gave him some extra they're
paying him like scale and stuff so but
how can it is illegal who knows man a me
can be can you do when you win a TV show
if you're if you're an illegal alien can
you do a TV show you could get to fill
out all the forms California will
probably buy on the house dude yeah yeah
yeah we had some questions that came in
and thank you though I wanted to say
that for choosing me over Chris D'Elia
when it comes to you know if something
happened to Bobby
and I like Chris and Chris but I'm glad
to know that you would prefer to have
somebody sensual around who's gonna care
about you in case I'm ever happen to Bob
I feel like you'd take me out to
breakfast the next day oh yeah I dine
apple some poi
baby if I can [ __ ] die and I'm in
heaven and you you're getting
physicalities with the Rat King I don't
[ __ ] very much I'm okay with that
yeah what if we're like 60 I don't give
a [ __ ] there's many other building every
trans yeah [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ]
rocket yeah yeah
[ __ ] spicy Roadrunner Santino that
[ __ ] that way house all right [ __ ]
ginger courage huh
okay so walking rage dude dude how many
in bombs does he have it as hell that's
what I wanna know
oh so you have questions what kind of
questions got a couple that came in from
the listeners yeah we is because of
Valentine's Day we had people send in
questions about their relationships and
see if you guys can give some advice
okay a few what's up do Bobby
kalila question for you all how do I
politely tell my girlfriend that she's
bad at telling stories she's just not
very efficient with her words and it
drags on and takes twists and turns and
comes up at the end and then is a sorry
that took forever thanks Maya
gun squad gang bruh thank you very much
for your support
yeah when I would do very nice of you is
when she tells a story I would look at
her and go that's great you should write
a script on that story no no no so that
she writes the script oh right right
that she actually uses these rights how
long this rotten page 70 of the script
yeah even happened yeah nothing's
happened it's about a parking she can
get a parking right and then and I set
up I'll set up like industry meetings
right so now she's in like I mean NBC
right whatever right yeah
with grace woo yeah right now just
pitching this idea and they're just
staring at her like you know I mean and
that's how she'll know and then they buy
it and then next thing you know Santino
and deliora in Iran are in it and then
you and me are there you know after they
fool around a couple years from now I
think what do you mean I know but what
do you do yeah what am i I have friends
grow girlfriends who are horrible
storytellers you know I'm all about just
keeping keeping things very brief I
don't even like long emails yeah if
you're close enough with her I don't
think there's anything wrong with saying
okay what's the general thesis of all of
this that's my sister oh he says that
actually and she says it in such a
jovial way so it doesn't offend the
other person and
joking way just be like alright gotta
wrap it up like what is yeah what you
know point a point B but just keep it
quick and I think that would probably
serve her for the rest of her life
you're the closest person to her do her
a favor yeah look you tell stories for
30 minutes long when they could be two
minutes short right and it's just not
fair it might prevent you from a job
opportunity to just you know yeah it's
just a blind spot you have that you did
you don't notice and I like your stories
but are too [ __ ] long yes I like you
sorta but they're too long I'll be
patient for like one of my niece
something wrong with her you know I
don't know what's wrong with her and
they have you know she would tell
stories for forever six six seven hours
but all night keep you up all night you
know so finally I would be like oh the
story pearl it police are here we're
pulling this story over we need to get
an ending to it right now you know so
she went like five minutes of like stuff
story police are here so you could do
that with your chick man drop that spz
on her brunt if she gets out up if she
gets out of line dude [ __ ] taser you
know I'm saying tase that [ __ ] man but
but you have great stories baby but most
with the girl you great stories babe
good pretty good
you like Hemingway I love it but like
that's the only author I know and I
wrote it but all the girlfriends I've
ever had but I've trained myself married
to pretend yeah and that's what most
relationships are right even with your
friends yeah but if she's about your
friends like I've been with guys and
like Santino's told me a story where I
fake laughed at it oh yeah yeah you
don't really think it's good right but
with you and the kind of rapport we have
where if he's telling me some dumb
[ __ ] story I'll roll my eyes and be
like wrap it up what do we what are you
trying to tell me yeah and he'll do the
same with you yeah I guess yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a level of a certain
point where it's like you're almost past
like the you know that each other care
enough and it's not going to be damaged
like whatever you know it's not gonna be
damaging where's in the first couple
months of a relationship or maybe even
first year to this guy looks younger
than us it could definitely be like you
know that could be breakup potential
it's later shut it
that's an energy vampire someone who
thinks they can sit there and tell a
story for 30 minutes and have your ears
at all time that's just brood yeah it
really is and that's I mean even as
entertainers like I feel bad doing over
50 minutes in a set it's like you know
these people paid but I don't want to
give them their money's worth but I also
don't want to sit there and just be up
here you know like a lot of comedy like
Chappelle will show up and just sit up
there and smoke a cigarette it's like
yes he's great but at the same time it's
like do I have to somebody 3 or 4 a.m.
to see your talent I saw Mencia do 5
hours in a row like I was hosting the
show I when he I brought him up on stage
hmm and then I went to the greenroom and
then next thing I know I wake up from
like a four hour sleep Wow and dream
room was the greenroom room was dark and
it woke up and I didn't know where you
know what time it was where I was and I
go what the [ __ ] you know and I listen
and he's still on stage and I look at
the [ __ ] clock and it's like 3:00
4:00 in the [ __ ] morning unbelievable
baffling man and that is and also this
guy right here I'm saying if it sounds
like it's just not gonna work out mm-hmm
right this guy yes I don't know if
you're if you're if that if it bothers
you so much that you're doing a video
and you're sending it to people podcast
and stuff but it's in its people I think
that he that he admires there we have a
young lady's perspective here today
which we don't have in all the times
that knife no you can't you can hold the
case to it and I'll hold this part I
think you should show her this episode
that'll solve it yeah this episode to
definitely help I mean but I think Sid
yeah being real with her book is also
you're gonna need somebody that you can
be real with at some point man you can
disagree opportunity for you to be real
and loving at the same time I love you I
love listening to you sometimes I feel
like your stories are too or just too
long and it's you know it's hard to be
to stay focus the whole time you know
when there are certain storytellers or
certain people who tell stories really
like was it May was it June was it you
know it was definitely July and they go
into these like unimportant parts of the
story yeah that destroys me when I'm
when I had to sit there and I'm I'm just
desperately waiting for the you know for
the gist yeah yeah because I'm living my
life
it's like I want to be supportive but at
the same time I'm not out here just
absorbing your [ __ ] for an hour when
it's not fine-tuned taking on stage and
get it tight and then bring it back to
the relationship what else is going on
we got another question from Australia
from Emma hi see you Bobby and kalila
Emma from Melbourne Australia this
little guy is six weeks old and he's
dead he's being and inconsiderate
bastard for example the other day I told
him to grab Weston in the morning so I
could have a sleep in and his response
was what about my sleeping and then last
night I asked him to get his get ready
in the bathroom put his work clothes on
in the bathroom in the morning so he
doesn't wake me up and he cracked the
shits so he's really being an
inconsiderate bastard and I was just
wondering what advice you have for him
and yeah please help him also for
Valentine's Day I got him tickets to
your show in Melbourne in May you're
very sweet good is it bud
what about forty Gang Gang mummy the
baby looks like about forty years old
and also the baby look like you've been
dating other babies in the neighbourhood
sexually content yeah yeah well I think
you could just even show him this video
and let him know a that obviously your
wife really cares about you because she
got your tickets to my show and she's
still thinking about the future of you
guys and doing something fun together
down the line so but at the in the
meantime she's thinking about some other
issues she would love a little bit more
maybe understanding who knows what other
stresses she's under so so she's the one
that carried the baby for nine months
and went through all the physical I mean
imagine I we will never get any
experience that yeah but what do you do
with a man who's not able to that type
of information isn't able to sink in mmm
look when there's just so wrapped up in
themselves anything their time is so
[ __ ] valuable let's say he maybe
let's suppose like he brings home you
know he's financially more you know he
brings on
the bacon what if he thinks his role is
to not do that because I have a friend
who has three kids and he doesn't feel
like he needs to participate in the kids
rearing or helping with a newborn Wow
because he makes most of the money and
so you just have to be clear about those
gender roles and because you're not okay
with what's going on I think you should
just be really clear with him and say
hey dude I'm exhausted I need your help
that's just the end of it all that's the
end of the story no I'm gonna argue
against it just for a second thought
yeah if the dude is a coal miner right
he has soot on him he wakes up at 6:00
in the morning has to take an elevator
to the you know in oh yeah gonna cook or
pour and whatever he's inhaling is like
giving him lung diseases right and he's
there for 12 hours [ __ ] getting iron
ore I don't know how they do it down
there you know Seven Dwarfs but my point
in any comes home and he's just dark you
know in certain just dirty and like
tired as [ __ ] I think that that dude
should be able to just take a bath and
go to sleep yeah possibly yeah it sure
is you're working at you know Kinkos
mm-hmm
right and you you're in charge of
stocking the highlighters mm-hmm you you
can help out yeah yeah I agree and that
somebody should be I agree I think that
there's definitely you things you expect
you're like oh well if I'm working you
think oh I expect that she should be
able to handle that right but it should
be communicated that's the thing it's
like it's what's going on I feel like
I'm tired when I get home and she's like
well I feel like I would love to get a
little bit rest in the morning because
it's a long day and then I stay up at
night with you to spend time with you
and you get home you know it's and
motherhood is so ice it can be very
isolating seems like it and you know
you're feeding a baby out of your own
body I will say though that there really
no is no excuse to not be considerate
and it sounds like even though this guy
wants some he's just not being
considerate right and my dad was a
really you know he brought home the
bacon he was a very very very busy man
but he was always really kind and
thoughtful and considerate to my mom
when she had two young babies and to
this day she's like there will be no
better example of
a man should take care of two young kids
given that as busy as he was yeah and he
was 70 years 70 years old Wow
he was an old guy yeah and he still
showed up at the same kind of vibe your
dad was super old oh that's another
thing with her in common and her menthe
dad was super old he was like 60 right
when he had you yeah yours was and they
were on the swim team right you guys
were on swim team yeah because we were
you know Filipino know what last lucky
sperm we swim fast
oh yeah last Lucky's firmly cemented s
yeah yeah I think yeah some
consideration could definitely help and
if you are doing that just let her know
why if there's a reason I think you just
got to communicate with it and be
vulnerable and maybe she's a little bit
scared I don't know if women get scared
sometimes after they have a kid you they
feel like you know maybe my huh you know
like my husband's gonna think different
of me or something I don't know maybe
there's a lot of fears going on and but
it's obviously that she cares because
she's doing something nice that for you
for the future to come do it to take you
to a comedy show whether it's mine or
anyone she's thinking about down the
road and so you know she's not obviously
thinking about she just wants a little
bit of help in the meantime she probably
spent some consideration is but she did
she tell him these grievances or I think
okay or maybe this is her way of telling
him in happy Valentine's Day well I can
say that but little Winston looks cute
as hell ma'am I'm buddy got a little uh
Doberman not a Doberman but something
some kind of real [ __ ] like a little
animal little fox or something like a
thick Fox and his name Winston did a
real Winston is a corgi in our building
with paralyzed back legs oh really and
he still alive yeah he is he's on wheels
Winston is on tell him what happened no
why would we end a Valentine's episode
telling Theo about our neighbor that
died oh I never died yeah and it's sad
his headboard was against our headboard
and I could feel when he was passing
away no wait a second yeah and he was in
hospice care and I told Bobby I'm like
I've just been feeling really heavy and
sure enough I talked to his family a
couple days after and he did pass away
when we were feeling it did he have HIV
no he died of liver CA
well he was nice and nice but he was a
good dude that doesn't turn people into
Saints yeah yeah yeah it's really sad
it is sad very sad young and vibrant
yeah very young and fit good as [ __ ] out
and handsome right Jesus mm-hmm and he
has had addiction issues no he just got
a beautiful Asian I think he was
fallacious
he was like six-30 asian not your kind
of five foot yeah nothing a little
worker bee we're talking about a king
our queen
yeah we've got one more so we don't okay
let's do one more yeah that was downer
but I feel
kalila and Bobbie my name is Julia and
I'm from Toronto and I love all of you I
love both of your podcasts Tiger belly
and this past weekend thank you I have a
question for you all considering your
own relationships what do you do about
being attracted to people outside of
your relationships and have you ever
felt inclined or the urge or desire to
step outside your relationship and cheat
thanks so much guys love you it's a
really complex question they're an easy
question though what is it well and
there's your two honey here you know I
want to see your answer and then I'll
answer based on your answer she already
said me not Chris if you go into a
relationship thinking that you cannot
have eyes for anybody else you're
setting yourself up for failure
if you go in thinking that yes I will
always I will probably find 50,000
people attractive in my lifetime but I
choose this person it's a lot less of a
burden to carry I tell you when I find
someone attractive yeah but I would I
don't I'm not threatened by that feeling
of attraction I just know that I'm
allowed to feel that way cuz I'm human
and therefore I don't feel the need it
doesn't become a temptation because I
own it right it becomes a temptation
when you try to suppress the feeling of
attraction and then all of a sudden it
feels like you like it becomes exciting
that temptation turns to excitement
because you're trying to suppress I also
honest oz a really good point any many
don't know is it many crushes yeah
of course we play candy crossed you all
the time yeah no but I'll like you know
you know I'll go to a certain like
coffee shop or whatever bathhouse yeah
yeah and there's a girl that's there
that's cute right my suits and then they
go oh you know I mean oh I'm a fan of
you know you know yeah and then you go
there do you yeah sorry
sorry go on and so I have these little
mini crushes running the day or over the
years but it's also you know I know that
I'm you know committed relationship with
her it doesn't you know I don't know
it's just I just don't cheat yeah and I
think those little mini crushes or those
little things make you realize oh that I
still have you know I'm a being enough
feelings you know and kind of exciting
exciting and I think that if it's makes
me exciting to kind of see your partner
to and remember that you did feel that
same feeling with them but fifty times
stronger when you first met them right
yeah and I think you just constantly
have to remind yourself that you you you
felt that way about your partner now I
think that you know people have their
own rules and relationships and people
have like open relationships but it
hasn't been hard being monogamous with
him
even though I was my last relationship
was with two men well I lived in I lived
with two men we had a great relationship
for several years we traveled together
it was respectful
it was great sounds good I never want to
do that again it was exhausting sounds
exhausting yeah yeah and sounds very
you've never thought it hasn't been an
issue at least for me you know I love
the way you framed it to like the way
that you see it like you know that it is
sure those things are gonna happen and
that's totally natural like to have
attraction at different people and if
you just see it as that and kind of be
glad that it happens that you have that
even that function in your brain that
you still even can have that feeling
that doesn't mean that's not in you and
still toward the other person for you
know 50 times the strength I also have a
friend I'm gonna say his name who's
marrying us kids Dom who whenever he
sees her he obviously gives her [ __ ]
eyes yeah yeah but he like looks are up
and down right and if she's turned away
he'll look at her ass and all that kind
of
you don't have like a little smile and I
watched him do it I fire that bro yeah
you know I get it right she's hot
yeah you know and I don't have jealousy
I don't have any and after your shows I
see women come up to him they kiss him
on the cheek they want to hug him they
want to flirt with him saying hey come
with us have drinks and I always I never
step in and I'm happy for him that he
gets to he's a cute talented man why
wouldn't why wouldn't they be attracted
to me I was attracted to him right
that's a good point yeah so funny it's a
you know it's so interesting it's like
you would want people to be now you want
them to work with it healthily whenever
they whenever they get that I saw a girl
she opened up a hatchback and she had a
bunch of wood chips back there and tried
to convince probably to get back in
there that a water bottle in there with
a little spout coming out of it oh damn
look empty that a candy cross like a big
sized iPad one that hasn't come out yet
and he was really tempted you could see
him almost get in there I was at Charlie
naturally I was like Charlie good nights
that Club mm-hmm and there's the first
of this ever happened I was started
first started dating kalila but we're
committed hmm and she grabbed my wrist
she let me blow you in the bathroom oh
wow and and I was like there's no way no
like that when you went home and changed
our facebook status to in a relationship
Wow was that I knew there was something
you were compensating for yeah I figured
you probably got a [ __ ] at this trip
no I never got a [ __ ] I know but I'm
pretty sure it came close and that's why
you went home and you were like I got it
no no and he does oh he has now we know
our boundaries but in the beginning he
didn't know what a bounder he was right
what it meant so in the beginning in our
first year together he would do things
like text a woman like I want to [ __ ]
you raw dog yeah and it was like this
postmates guy or like he would just go
out of his way to you know he would take
that temptation go a little bit too far
verbally that's what I do
that's what I'd done but then I just
made it really clear with him I said
look that's my line you know you know
light flirting you know innocent stuff
all good but to tell her you have plans
to [ __ ] her raw dog yeah
that's my line that's my boundary right
and you just have to be really clear
about your lines with each other in your
relationship I like that
Wow but you learning some stuff today
yeah I mean I and I you know I was in a
relationship and I didn't do that good
of having boundaries and stuff like that
and now that I've been off pornography
I've felt a lot less tempted to really
engage with women as much as I used to
like it used to be like a lot more of a
temptation for me and now it's like I
don't even that some of that temptation
is going away where it's not even it's
just like a bad habit almost and I don't
feel like I have to just cling to any
type of attraction that a woman sends to
me because there's making it hard for me
to you know even be in a relationship
because I was just acknowledging other
like attractions that would come in yeah
I had this weird thing that if somebody
like showed interest in me that if I
didn't in some way acknowledge it or
return it even like it just like a hug
or like a swanky face or a smile or
something then then like I was like
letting them down somehow or something
so I think I still have a lot to learn
in that space it's also very difficult
as a performer I think so I think that
you guys are in a completely different
difficult
I've never gotten attention in the same
way that you guys get attention so I
don't know how I would feel if dick was
thrown in my direction you know and the
frequency that you know you guys get it
will you learn from you learn from guys
like there are faithful dudes you know
you learn from like Greg Fitzsimmons a
lot of the redheads Bilborough
you know half agents - Steve Byrne oh
yeah al Madrigal oh yeah like that they
they're they're pretty you know Daniel
day camp when it came to a monogamous
guys yeah burn or although because
they're married now that used to be
players yeah you know mean and they have
made a choice and but we you and I also
know a lot of guys that don't do that
that are just straight [ __ ] hitchhikers
yeah I do think though that men and
women need to get that out of their
system yeah and especially women just as
many dudes as you can so it's getting
out of your sister
and some of its like you know these days
it's almost like you don't end up with
someone to that you want to have a
partner that it's like you guys can
raise a family if you're having a family
like some people they get married it's
all based on sensuality it's nice huh
and then they but then that goes away
and then then up you know they have two
kids and they're divorced and it's like
you know it's definitely interesting to
figure out what ingredients need to be
in a relationship for you know for you
to be then parents and then it's their
never adjust the same ingredients for
every relationship we're because I think
that Bobby and I are little atypical
mm-hmm and what works for us certainly
might not work for somebody else or the
cat the we're very brutally honest and
some people find that really
uncomfortable that we he shares pictures
with prostitutes that he's been with
with me yeah you know he's like look at
this is when I [ __ ] us around the
motel and it doesn't really faze me that
might not work for other people that
kind of just transparency they call it
being very clear photos around my house
like if you're looking drawers you'll
just see me with like oh yeah and like
really seedy places on my shoulder yeah
maybe with I have wings on you know I
mean I'm gonna mountain top I have a
real I've done some crazy fields thank
you dude anyway that's a great
Valentine's I gotta eat man the slep
King wait Queens so much to have I love
you so much
hey what are you gonna come on our soon
oh come on Excel yeah am i one day I
think so
you're Monday it'll be great but you
know I'm good good to see you again too
happy Valentine's Day I Love You Man
holla
thank you yeah thank you
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]